28 year old right-hander aaron nola who
was seven and seven in era of 4.33 and
aaron is making his 26th start of the
year john i think the only thing you can
say is that if he can do anything close
to what he did his last timeout until he
should be fine tonight
yeah they should i don't care how hot
some of these diamondbacks hitters are
it's it it's going to be a long day for
him if he is commanding now the 1-2
pitch swung on and it's hit in the air
to center field it's not deep jamkowski
coming in and then over to his left a
little bit fighting the sky but he makes
the catch
another one popped up this one on the
infield gregorius
the shortstop
makes the catch
the one-two pitch from noah
popped up
freddie galvez
toward the left field line gives way to
oduba herrera who makes the catch good
communication
and the side is retired one two three
the right-hander taylor widener
coming off a win at colorado on sunday
as a matter of fact his last three
starts have been really good each one of
them five innings he's given up a total
of seven hits and four runs in 15
innings in his last three starts the
walks have been a little bit of an issue
and this billy's ball club leads the
national league and walks since the
all-star break so something to keep an
eye on here tonight
wing in a minute good start for taylor
widener strikes out double herrera
harper in his last six games hitting 381
with two home runs
and he shoots it the other way peralta's
going back and he is not going to get it
it's off the wall harper hustling on his
way to second the throw is wide that's
his third double the series
runners at first and second two outs
on the ground knocked down by walker
christian walker makes a tremendous play
and saves a run there's one for
norristown p.a powered by mom's
meatballs no score after one
lined up in the pitch swing and a miss
and he got him
first strikeout for aranola
gets walker on a high fastball and it's
one out here in the second
curveball on the outside corner strike
three calls a called strike and then a
foul ball you see that just
gave up on i mean
swinging a miss got him with a curve
three strikeouts of the inning for
aranola
[Applause]
2-2 is right there called strike three
second strike down for taylor
two outs in the second but that's a
pretty good looking pitch right there
pounds a fastball in there at the knees
over the heart of the plate
chops with fastball at rojas at second
and they get the force on galvez
on to the third at citizens bank park
diamondbacks and the phillies no story
it's that sharply out to second on one
hop
and sigoura throws him out
kicks and deals and big swinging a miss
again and that is the fourth strikeout
for aranola
that one's over to the right side segura
is up with it
and he makes the play
side is retired almost every day
there's a broken bat ball that's caught
by
widener a nice play the bag goes all the
way out to the second baseman rojas
just
shatters that bat little soft liner
taylor has a chance to regroup and reach
up and
snag that one out of midair the barrel
the bat ends up out at second base
no harm done one out for segura first
time a flight out to left and he lines
that one into center field of base hit
just the second hit today for the fills
but it's a one out base runner for bryce
harper coming up
that one's out to left center field on
the run is mccarthy it is gone
it slips right over the small fence a
two-run opposite field home run
and the phillies take the lead here in
the bottom of the third
[Music]
and they just continued to stay away
away away from bryce so what do you do
3-0 pitch was a fastball away for strike
one
they tried to go
back out there and
yeah he's
he's seeing the ball too good right now
to pitch him in one spot fifth time in
bryce harper's career he has at least 25
home runs in a season
crowd here at citizens bank is sensing
number five the o2 pitch swing and a
miss and there it is three straight
change up
this change up right here
yeah just uh there you see it the circle
change
executed perfectly by aaron nola
swag gonna miss 94. a little up in the
zone
six strikeouts for nola he's allowed one
hit through forwarding so far
[Applause]
popped up
the changeup was a good pitch
out front behind second is dede
gregorius he makes the catch
brad miller backhands noel is there to
cover two outs
[Applause]
out in front sort of a change-up and
seven strikeouts for aranola josh rojas
over two josh has flight out grounded
out
that's ripped down the line it's a fair
ball and ahmed's on the move
all the way in the corner for harper
here comes nick
he will score and rojas is in there at
third
it's a two-to-one ball game
here comes joe girardi that one got all
the way into the corner on bryce harper
and that's going to be it for nola
[Applause]
and meter gets it up in the air we'll
see if this is deep enough
jankowski in center here comes rojas
jankowski's got an arm but not enough
and josh is in there
and meter of the rbi and we're tied to
two so bases loaded now for jt real muto
with one out
and he hits it sharply into left center
field to base hit one run score here
comes herrera
he'll score it's a two run single for jt
and the phillies take the lead it's 4-2
[Applause]
the diamondbacks now have been on the
corners 2-2 pitch
swing miss he got him with the splitter
that's a big out
3-2 pitch
swag in a miss he got him
he went back to the split
back-to-back strikeouts
kicks and the pitch ground ball right
side segura has it over to first
in time to get the out and what a job by
hector neris as he walks works around
the lead off walk in the error and able
to get out of this inning unscathed
get the time run up to the plate here
comes walker
and a high fly ball to center field will
it stay in the yard and it is gone
and we are tied at four
there's one for norristown pa mama was
happy on her feet
and probably gonna have a combination of
meatballs and cake pops tomorrow
the whole walker gang
our team at pitch hit stayed in the ball
game he's in the pitcher's spot
martay launches one deep to center and
you can kiss that goodbye
cattell martay
[Applause]
walker in the ninth and martay in the
10th and it's six to four
loud contact wow
tape and pitch hits stayed in the ball
game he's in the pitcher's spot
martay launches one deep to center and
you can kiss that goodbye
cattell martay
[Applause]
walker in the ninth and martay in the
tenth and it's six to four
loud contact wow
so brad miller will step in how about a
game tire right here right
and a high fly ball to deep right field
we are tied up
it's a 6-6 game here in the 10th inning
the emotions are up
they're down
they're up again
and now segora with runners at first and
second
but he fights it off down the right
field line
and traps in for a base hit and the
phillies are going to win the ball game
gene segora comes through with his
seventh career walk off as the phillies
win it here in the bottom of the 11th
inning
you